I was told I have to tell you who I am
and why I'm here and not somebody else.
And uh, that's very funny for me.
I never do that. But at any rate,
I should tell you,
as was indicated,
the first 50 years of my professional
life was bent becoming a certified quantum
mechanic. I know where from I speak
when I talk about quantum mechanics,
I started out being a particle
physics phenomenologist.
I moved into formal quantum field
theory and in particular non-paternity
additive techniques in
quantum field theory.
That led to my moving into a solid state
physics and condensed matter theory.
And then finally I ended up talking,
working on the subject that I'll
be talking to you about today.
Now obviously I had no
restrictions on what I did. Okay.
I had the world's greatest job. So the
real question is why did I leave it?
I mean I told people my job
description when I got tenure at slack,
it was a one liner and said,
you are to do anything you feel like
doing for the rest of your time here.
As long as you think it's
good science. So, I mean,
why the hell did I retire
to do this nonsense?
And the answer is because six years ago
I co-invented dynamic quantum clustering
guard DQC and I created the company,
I mean Stanford Patent that it right away.
And there are three patents that surround
this technology now and my company
controls the exclusive
rights to those patents. Um,
but
the reason I wanted to make the company
go and it was clear Stanford wasn't
gonna make it go.
Their idea of how they develop something
is they tell the person who invented it,
go out and make a company.
And, and it, you know,
you can try to avoid that for a
couple of years and then you say,
it really isn't going to happen
unless I do it. So I did it.
And why?
Because I'm not a bad physicist
and I've done a lot of neat things.
I never saved anybody's life. And I
think this has the potential to do that.
And that's why I'm here
today to talk to you.
And it's also why I've changed
what I'm going to talk about. Okay.
So what is dynamic quantum clustering?
It has a really different
way of looking at data.
It opens up stuff that I don't think
anybody really does except the QC.
Uh,
it basically solves the problem of
how do I find unexpected information.
I know nothing about the data.
I'm looking for unexpected information
that I don't know how to look for and
it's hidden in my large, noisy,
messy, big dataset. I dimension.
Okay.
Or I liked the other quote,
how can I find the needle in
my multidimensional haystack
if I have no clue what
a needle is and there's no
guarantee it's in my haystack. Okay?
So I need a way of looking for things
which can't use a predefined search
strategy. Okay. One way to do this,
Adam saws in the audience and we had a
fight about this. I love losing fights.
I lost one to Adam. He said, well, it's
generally clustering. And I said, no,
it's not. And then I went
back and I said, well,
it's been a long time since I went to
Wikipedia and look up the definition of
clustering. I said, clustering didn't
mean looking for a long complex,
extended structures in the data. Well,
it turns out that's wrong. I was wrong.
Clustering since I looked last.
Got that as part of the thing.
Not too many things to do it,
but that's what it is.
But the typical ways of
looking for unsupervised stuff
will be hierarchical or k
means clustering. There are
things called DB scan, HDB scan,
the current gold standard for
biology work, t Sni, HDB scan,
a Gaussian modeling.
All of these things have
several requirements which
we have to get rid of if
we're looking for unexpected stuff.
One is they need to clean the data.
They have tuneable parameters. They build
assumptions as to what clusters are,
how many clusters there are
and what you're looking for.
All of that gets in the way of letting
the data tell you what's in the data.
Okay? We need a way of letting
the data talk to itself.
A DQC can do that.
So how is DQC different?
This is the 30,000 foot view of it.
We can return to it towards the end of
my talk if I don't run out of time when
people let me talk over and that is uh,
what DQC does is it uses the data
itself to create a proxy function,
a function that is a proxy
for the density of the data.
This function has the property
wherever there's locally more data,
it has a minimum.
If there's a region of dense data
along some curve it has a trough,
which is,
it has points of inflection in the car
basically once you've got this function,
the next problem which occurs,
think of this as a topographical map.
So I've drawn it in three dimensions
and the data is distributed.
There are rivers in this map,
river beds and the stream beds where
the data is more dense and of course
because of fluctuations
in they just statistical
fluctuations, systematic errors,
the data will be distributed up
along the banks of those streams.
So the name of the game is we just let
everybody rolled downhill into the stream.
The nearest point in the stream,
you will see a movie that does that.
That is DQC is just the movie.
The analysis is the movie. Okay.
And then, uh, the stream beds will appear.
You'll have understood the structure
of density variation in the data.
And then if there's more data
at one end of the stream,
then another things will slowly
flow downstream to the ocean.
The whole movie telling
you stuff about the data,
the time to reach the stream bed is
a measure of how far the data was.
So just counting frames,
you are able to get a measure on the data,
uh,
a metric on the data, which is how
far you are from the stream bed. Okay.
Uh, there are three knows that defined
why DQC is really different. Okay.
And why it's better,
faster and cheaper if I were trying to
pitch you and sell you something. Okay.
So first no hypotheses. I mean, you know,
the typical thing when
somebody has a data project,
they put a bunch of
smart people in a room.
They yell at each other for several days.
They come up with a hypothesis and then
they find out that hypothesis is wrong
and they go back into the room and
they hate each other at the end of this
process because they've been yelling at
each other. But it takes a lot of time.
Analysts are expensive,
they're time is money and so,
but worse, a hypothesis biases
the result you can find.
You've already gone in with an assumption
of what the data has to tell you.
You don't want to do that. The other
thing is you don't clean the data.
Now I've been warned and Google, I have
to be very careful about saying that,
so I'll be careful a little bit.
Okay.
The whole question of
cleaning data is a huge issue.
There are many things you can do to data
including burning it that I can't fix.
Okay? Uh, but in the sense
that I only want your raw data.
Okay? That's what I work
with. People ask me, you know,
do you want the raw data or the process
data? And I said, I want the raw data.
And the guy says to me, nobody
works with the raw data. It's like,
I want the wrong data. I don't want
your fingerprints all over this data.
You've already messed it up
as far as I'm concerned. Okay.
So you don't preprocess
the data to remove noise.
You don't process it to try to get out
systematic artifacts that you know about.
You just live with them.
It'll be fine.
They'll take care of
themselves in the process. Uh,
if the data's gap in columns,
think of the data generically
is some big spreadsheet.
If there are gaps in the columns,
I don't care.
I have plenty of examples where gap
data work just fine. Okay. I mean,
I'll put a minus one in for something
like that. Any kind of substitution,
I needed a number in there, but it doesn't
have to be a sensible number. Okay. Uh,
so if I don't have to clean my data,
I've already saved the
gigantic amount of time. Okay.
That's typically the place where an
enormous amount of time is wasted.
And then, I mean, I know
people where you say,
first thing your analyst comes in and
says, well, we have to clean your data.
And then he goes away for six months
and then it comes back and says,
I couldn't clean your data. So the
project's over pay me. Okay? Uh,
no.
The analyst's time is money and you have
the danger again of throwing the baby
out with the bath water.
If you don't know what you're looking for,
starting to clean it means you're going
to throw away everything but what you
think you might be interested in.
And the third thing is you don't need
expert knowledge in the first stage of an
analysis. That doesn't mean
subject matter experts are needed.
It means you run the analysis,
you see what you see,
and then you call them the
subject matter expert to say,
what the hell am I seeing
over here? Okay? And so, uh,
of course,
subject matter experts or the most
expensive analysts you're going to find.
So not wasting their time in
the beginning is a big deal.
Here you see three analyses,
okay? Now this is fun,
okay? This is one we completely
understand. This was done as an exercise.
This is Sloan digital sky survey data.
These are 350,000 galaxies.
The coordinates are the angles theta
and Phi on the sky, and the red shift,
meaning the distance of the galaxy from
us. You've read the New York Times,
I hope most of you or else Facebook showed
it to you or something and they told
you that
galaxies are distributed in filaments.
The elementary structure
of high density and voids.
This shows you at the beginning.
It's not so easy to see.
The way that's done is very
complicated and took a long time.
This is DQC running on that data,
pulling the data,
the galaxies back to the higher density
regions. That is the right answer.
So number one, that's
impressive, but number two,
what's more impressive is the structure
of what I'm showing you because I don't
know of any other way to see a complex
interlocking structure of filaments like
that. The real structure of the
data using any other cluster,
the reality that's not
possible in my knowledge here.
You're looking at data from
a hyperspectral camera.
It starts out looking like a hairball
and it contracts to this extended
structure of filaments. That's the kind
of thing I was telling you in this case.
That stuff is related to things that
are really going on on the ground,
on the ground.
This is a picture of a quarry in upstate
New York and the camera is a Mega Patho
megapixel camera that's taking a
frequency spectrum for the half a million
pixels and 512 frequency.
So I have a half a million,
512 dimensional pieces of data.
And the question is which ones
look more like one or nothing.
Why is that interesting? Because light
is reflected from the ground. I suppose.
I am the military,
which is not my favorite customer,
but let's say I'm in the military and
I have a tank in a desert and has been
camouflage to look like the sand.
Well,
it's been camouflage to look like
the sand and the visible frequencies,
but it doesn't look like the sand
and the nonvisible frequency.
So if I look at who's
like one another and area,
the shape of the tank will
appear in the data. Okay.
And it will be visible to
a hyperspectral camera,
which can be mounted in a drone and
flown over area. So that's pretty cool.
It's also have used the Coca
Cola and Pepsi Cola course.
They're the biggest corn growers
in the world and they, uh,
have huge fields of corn.
They need the high fructose corn syrup,
which is killing us all. But
that's fine. This is business. And
at any rate,
this can find problems in the fields and
it can do it in a very effective way.
So that's a cool thing about that. On
the very far left, there is cancer data.
And that's what I want to
talk to you about today.
And why do I want to talk to
you about the cancer data?
Cancer is a problem that everybody
understands is a big deal.
We've all lost people.
We love the cancer. Okay?
Uh, you also all know
cancer is a hard problem.
So if I show you stuff you
never knew about cancer data,
I hope that impresses you, that we've seen
something that nobody has seen before.
Okay? Uh, and so that will
be where the focus is.
But before I do that,
let me give you a little bit more
of the story of what you see.
Okay. Because when you see the DQC
movie and something like that appears,
this is sort of the, uh, the
progenitors of the zoo of shapes that,
so up in the movie,
if the data had little
regions on the left,
which were obviously separable
clusters DQC we'll show you points.
The points will be moved together
to the centroid of the region. Okay.
If the data has something which,
let's say I, Ozzy would say, oh,
that's a candidate for aggression.
And then they call in their
favorite regressor and say,
please give me a model for this data.
DQC We'll show you the line that
it would have regressed them. Okay.
And I'll,
I'll show you how that could possibly
happen cause it seems strange and if there
is a flare, which people talk about
places where the day to join showing you,
oh, this has been going on this way for
a long time and then two different things
can happen and the data ends up in
to slowly changing characteristics.
Then DQC we'll show you that and
if you'll look carefully there,
you're seeing it.
Okay.
The flares are just completely
revealed and it happens automatically.
You're not doing anything to extract
that from the data. DQC is doing that.
And finally finding circles and things,
which are the problems everybody likes
to talk about. It's a piece of cake.
I don't care about it. Okay.
It happens when it happens.
All right. What's automatic
regression? Cause that's a crazy idea.
There is a posting on linkedin that I did,
which I called Turbo charging,
uh, predictive analytics.
But what was it really about?
It was really about how you could have
knocked 200 years off the discovery of
the ideal gas law had you
had this technology. Okay.
Why do I say that?
Because Boyle and Charles 18 hundreds of,
so they identify Boyle's
law in Charles's law.
They're looking either at
how p and V are related.
If you hold teeth fixed
or p and t are related,
if you hold the fixed and
then it's 200 years later,
the Corinthia Dory Says No,
no p Times v is Tate.
Okay.
And getting all that put together and
dealing with the statistical problems in
the data and everything else.
It's a huge problem.
So I did this as a fun exercise.
I said,
suppose I generate 6,000 independent
values of p and V and then calculate t and
if I was able to plot in three
dimensions few hundred years ago,
then I would have seen something that
looks a lot like the red surface there.
I can tell you what that red surfaces,
it's a messed up version of
what I would have seen. Now.
That would be cool because once you see
a two dimensional surface, you finished,
you've said,
oh there's a law of physics because
not everyone is a law of physics.
If I'm now teaching in my class.
Right.
A Law of physics is the statement that
not everything you can measure about a
system is independent.
If you know some of the variables,
you can predict the other ones.
That's what gives you control.
That's what lets you make refrigerators.
Okay. Had they just had the surface,
they would have been in the position to
start the engineering program to build
the first refrigerator. Okay?
That's all they needed. Okay,
so you don't need the formula yet.
The surface a look up table,
you know, if you were my age, you would
remember when science and co-signs,
we're not cotton at the computer,
but you actually went to look at tables
of signed some coast signs and then you
interpolated the values to get
the number. You want it. Okay?
So here you would have
seen that right away,
all of that power would
be at your disposal.
The problem is data is never that good.
Data is messy.
So what I did was I took
down 6,000 points in,
generated another 66,000 points by taking
each PV and t value and multiplying it
by a number chosen from three independent
random distribution centered at one
with a width of about 0.1.
So this 10% error is roughly in that data
and the fuzzy blue surface is what you
see. Now what's true if it is actually
an underlying surface in the data,
and I messed it up that way,
that random distributions,
the high density region is the surface.
So what you're seeing is DQC coalescing
the data down onto the nearest high
density region, which is the surface and
then it buries itself in the surface.
Now it buries itself in the red surface.
The red surface is the best answer I
could have gotten because I took every 12
points that I had generated from a
single point and I averaged them.
And because of course I have
a small set of statistics,
the mean isn't the surface,
it's a little bit thing.
So that bread surfers shows you the
degree to which the data is messed up,
which would have been
improved by having more data.
And then the only question is why is it
pulling away from the edge in the later
frames? By the way, you're
looking at a thousand frames.
All of the interesting Cathy happens in
the first 60 then the thing stops moving.
Why did it stop moving? Because the
central region has roughly equal density.
And so DQC has no reason to move
the points around anymore. Okay?
It's pulling away from the edges for the
same reason the proxy function goes up
where there's no data sharply.
And so data that's out in that region
rolls down and pulls in from the surface
and then looks around and says, oh, no
problem. I'll stop right here. Okay.
So that's what I mean
by automatic regression.
So that means basically
if there are formulas,
unknown relations hidden in your data,
what will the QC do?
It'll regress the stuff
automatically to the formula.
Then if there's a variation
in the distribution of the
data, it'll slowly change.
That's why the whole movie matters.
First.
You see the stuff happen and then it'll
slowly change in response to small
variations.
All right,
so now I'm going to go to cancer data and
I'm going to try to finish this all in
the requisite amount of
time. So basically, uh,
this is a problem where,
uh,
I gave a talk at Seti and uh,
someone who shall remain nameless in the
audience noticed that this was sort of
interesting.
And he said,
I have a biologist friend who would love
to talk to you about this and it's on
the end. He said, well,
this is a really great idea and I'd like
to do stuff with you and collaborate.
But first,
in order to have my clients believe you,
we need to do a problem that biologists
will understand. I said, fine.
So he went to an Nih database that
had 25,000 tumors in it and uh,
it had all kinds of DNA sequence
information. It had MRN,
a expression information for each tumor
and a whole bunch of other things.
He pulled out 10% of that data and they
were five different kinds of tumors.
There was a bladder cancer,
Glioblastoma,
multiforme or we all know what that is
now cost. That's what John Mccain has.
Okay.
Low Grade Gliomas,
which are same cell but a
much less serious cancer.
They're all serious ovarian
cancer and thyroid cancer.
The colors on the left are the
colors I colored the data with.
So he would see it. You're looking
at, well, when I first did this,
I did the Svd de composition for
the 73,800 MRN a jeans I was given.
Okay. And I saw that
shape, I clustered it,
saw that the cancer
separated in an obvious way.
And from that DQC has an algorithm for
pulling out the most important genes for
that shape.
Having done that,
what you're seeing there is exactly
the same starting point, uh,
but for only the 48 genes that were
identified as important and basically what
do you see? You immediately see the
brain cancer separate like crazy.
The glioblastoma multiforme is very
different from the low grade Gliomas,
the thyroid cancers cluster,
but they don't call as to
a single disease. I mean,
remember the colors are a histologist
looked at the cell and said,
this is thyroid cancer. And
I'm telling you, no, it's not.
These are all different thyroid cancers.
If I had sensitivity
information to specific drugs,
all I have to do is recolor that plot.
And I say, well, yeah, it's true.
Your drug doesn't cure
everybody's thyroid cancer,
but it cures these siree
cancers 100% of the time. Okay.
This is the beginning of meeting
the promise of precision medicine.
Okay. When you can see that these
things are not single diseases. Okay,
sure.
I like questions.
They're SVD axes. Okay. They're linear
combinations of genes, okay. Uh,
that doesn't mean
anything. I mean, I can't,
I every point is identifiable all the
time as a particular point in the original
Dataset.
So we can reach in and say,
I want to know about these guys and I'll
pull out the raw data for you instantly.
Sved sved is the Swiss army knife of
all this stuff and I'm bringing coals to
Newcastle, but I'll say it anyway. Um,
all it's doing is finding a good set
of coordinates, the plot, the data,
the first three dimensions of the ones
in which the data has the biggest that
extent, the next three. It has less you,
if you look at that at the beginning,
there's no separation between these guys.
They're,
the separation occurs very quickly because
not of what's going on in the first
three dimensions, but what's going
on in the other 48 to see everything.
We're searing here, all 48
genes and playing a role, okay?
The reason these guys separate so fast
and it looks so different from everybody
else's, when you reach in
and pull out the clusters,
you find out instead
of expressing 48 genes,
they only express 24 48 dimensions.
They live in a different place and
that's reflected in the clustering in the
first three dimensions, okay?
So yes, if I wanted a bore,
you have silly or maybe excite you,
but run out of time,
I could plot all 48 dimensions for you,
but you're seeing
basically what's going on.
What I want to focus you on is the
red guys and the ovarian cancer guys.
The cyan guys are not moving very much,
and the first question
you'd like me to answer,
I hope is why aren't they moving at all?
They look like they're so close together.
Well,
they're not close together
and 48 dimensions. That's
why they're very different.
Okay. However, let's, uh,
the first question you would have asked,
right,
is what happens if you pull
48 random genes out? Okay.
And do the same game,
2,400 tumors, random genes.
That's what happens. I don't know
if you noticed it. Let's go back.
Look very careful at the evolution.
It's about 10 frames,
emotion and then it all stops.
Random data always does that.
Random data doesn't cluster
in any significant way.
That is what DQC shows you when
there's nothing to look at in the data.
So this is not random genes
that are going to do the job.
That doesn't mean there's not something
amazing going on in a lot of jeans. Okay?
Here, just to show you what you can do
with the data once you have the evolution.
This, because I was challenged,
somebody said, well,
you have to tell people what the gold
standard is doing on this date as how the
gold points you see there.
Cause it's the gold standard is t SNI
HDB scan when applied to this data,
it finds brain cancer.
But if you look carefully,
it finds equal amounts of
cluster in the Glioblastoma.
Multiforme or,
and in the low grade Gliomas,
it's not distinguishing glial
cell cancers, one from the other.
Okay. And that's true of every
cluster that HDB scan finds.
So HDB scan can tell thyroid,
it can tell ovarian,
but it can't tell apart the
brain cancers it fails on them.
And there's a reason, some of which we
understand for why that's happening.
And it'll happen in a lot
of data sets like this.
And the reason is there's much more than
one thing happening in this dataset and
we have to be able to go through and pull
out all the different things that are
happening. Okay. But as you see,
the competition doesn't
do too well on this,
whereas DQC separates the glial
cancers immediately from one another.
They really are very different.
If you average energy and expression and
compare them, they're very different.
Okay. These are different diseases.
However, the thing you should notice,
cause it's sort of fun and stuff about it,
will be in the paper as it forms
to begin with. You see an arch,
their intermediate frames.
The first thing that happened is there's
a stream bed in which you see a low
dimension structure that interpolate
between Glioblastoma multiforme and low
grade Glioma.
Understanding that could be very,
very important in treatment.
Okay.
Why is it important that in the
beginning of the GLIOBLASTOMAS extended?
I know this from personal sad experience.
My first wife died of
Glioblastoma multiforme and
before at the stage where John
Mccain is now, the doctors come
to you and give you a choice.
They say the choices, are
you going to have radiation
or not have radiation? Well,
it turns out Glioblastoma multiforme
or can go one of two ways.
When confronted with radiation,
it can become much more malignant
or it can get a little bit better.
We ended up in the bad side of that day,
but nobody knows how to tell them apart,
but since initially this
is an extended structure,
the hope would be if we had the radiation
information, we could give advice.
Are you a candidate for radiation or
you're not a candidate for radiation
because that's also not
completely one disease.
There's just a few other
little things that we know.
We know something about
the age of the patient.
I have no information about uh,
their response to the drugs.
And I have no information about
their response to radiation,
but the Datasat has age.
So always in these plots,
the left hand side is the original
analysis colored by diagnosis,
the right hand thing,
the red points are people over 40.
The blue points are people under 40.
Maybe somebody is equal to
40. I don't know. At any rate,
the interesting thing is the Glioblastoma
multiforme is mostly people over 40.
The low grade gliomas in this dataset
or mostly people under 40. Okay.
If we look out here,
remember these guys didn't cluster well.
Well,
there's a reason these guys over
here are red are older people.
There are tumors. I mean why are older
people interesting? As you get older,
the errors in your genome crop up,
the MRAA expression will become more
random and therefore they should not look
like younger people even for the
same quote disease. They don't.
And so the reason these guys don't
coalesce and the blue ones do is the blue
ones are younger people with a less messed
up genome but still big variation in
the genome.
The only other piece I have is the the uh,
stage of the cancer. Okay. Cancer
is a stage one, two, three, four,
four, a four B. Okay. On this plot,
the stage three and four
cancers a yellow and red.
So it's always the same movie.
Oh,
I've done has changed the
coloring according to the
information that I have from
sources that have nothing
to do with the genome.
Well apparently I have
nothing to do with the genome.
And you notice the guys that I told
you where the red and the scion,
they ovarian,
they don't move well.
They also are the ones that are higher
stage cancers more messed up genomes.
You expect them to be different
in 48 dimensions and they are,
they don't cluster. These guys
do. And this edge out here,
the yellow ones are there they are again,
the more messed up genomes and they
shouldn't cluster with the blue ones and
they don't.
So this is how you just work your way
through the analysis at the first stage.
Okay. But then the question
comes up, what happens? I mean,
I'm just trying to lead you right
through the questions as they appear.
What happens if I take these 48
genes out? I do. I see anything.
Okay.
Do you want to vote?
Somebody wanted to take a guess.
How am I going to see something?
Am I going to see Confetti? I'm
I going to see a mess. All right.
Nobody wants to guess. That's
what I see. Okay. Stunning.
A totally different shape has appeared.
The 48 genes are out.
They were the most dominant ones.
And defining the shape,
it doesn't mean that went away.
There's another shape. Okay.
And here's where I get my comeuppance.
So I'll tell you about it. Okay.
I looked at this and I said,
oh look, that's pretty good.
I think what I'm seeing,
because these are not really separated,
what I'm seeing, and I said this to my
colleague, Alex felt this, uh, that,
um,
I'm seeing the,
the ordinary behavior of healthy cells.
And Alex said, I don't
believe that. He said,
I believe what we're seeing is that cancer
infiltrates the cell and hijacks the
cellular machinery and leaves,
fingerprints all over the gene expression
of the rest of the genes in the system.
And I said, that's ridiculous. I know that
the way that thing is going to cluster,
here's the Glioblastoma and the others
are going to be the same cluster.
I have a lot of experience
running this stuff.
You should never say you understand
that 48 dimensions later,
the Glioblastoma and the low grade
glioma separate from one another.
Beautifully. He's right. I'm wrong. I
had a great day. I love being wrong.
So if I look down here in dimensions four,
five and six,
this is what I was telling you.
The red guys live in an entirely different
place from the same guys. So in fact,
we just found out ovarian cancer is
not dark. It's not bladder cancer.
But it takes other dimensions
to see that fact. Okay?
So, uh, it's just dangerous to guests. I
don't care how much experience you've had.
The good thing is I can put
all the bias I want it to.
What I think is going to happen.
TQC does what it wants.
That's what it did. That's what we saw.
That was the end of the story. All right,
so we're at, I'm told I have
like 10 minutes left. Uh,
is that about right?
I promised
John that I would pull back the curtain
a little bit on the quantum mechanics.
That means half of you should
go to sleep. Okay. Okay.
Uh, I'm sorry about that. Uh, the,
I didn't do this to you. Blame him.
Okay.
Uh,
what do I first want to emphasize
quantum mechanics in? This is a trick.
I am abusing what I know about quantum
theory to do a problem that should be
done classically, but it wouldn't be
computable if it was done. Classically,
I need an approach,
which is immensely paralyzable.
If I have to do gradient descent to
move things down the cliff and there's
millions of points and
hundreds of dimensions.
I don't know how many of you have done
gradient descent while you do in machine
learning. So, uh, in fact, you know,
not so easy to find 800 minima
and characterize their shape.
Okay,
in 500 dimensions.
So we need something else we need as the
person who taught me quantum mechanics,
Bob server would say we need a trick
and in this case the trick is quantum
mechanics. Okay, now do.
I said we're going to create a function
that's a proxy for the density of the
data and we're going to
do that for two reasons.
Then we're going to move the points. Okay,
I'm going to move ahead a little bit.
So here is what the manual Parson
and infinite long time ago,
but had you read basic books on data
mining or statistical analysis you would
have found at Parson in fact invented
something called the Parson estimator.
He said,
for each data point in n dimensions,
I'll write a Gaussian a Belker.
I'll add them all up and I'll have a
function and where there's more data,
I should have a maximum and was less data.
I should have a minimum.
The problem is what you see here,
the one parameter and the Gaussian
Gamma varies by a few percent,
and what you see in terms of
maximum minima changes dramatically.
The function is exquisitely
sensitive to parameters anyway,
characterizing lots of Maxima in a
function in n dimensions is very,
very difficult.
So the first step that faced us was,
how do we keep this idea but change what
we do so that the function we have is
not sensitive to changes the parameters.
You can change parameters by 20%
and you'll see the same structure.
Okay? This function has
a lot of Nice properties.
The first of it is it's
positive everywhere.
It's either a zero or positive that makes
it a candidate for an Eigen function
of a problem in quantum mechanics.
Now, if you're a physicist like me,
you know that problems
in quantum mechanics,
when you find the eigen functions of a
potential of the force law for what's
going on in the problem,
wherever there is a maximum in the
function or wherever there's a minimum and
the potential, there'll be a small
maximum of the eigen function.
Okay? Or a point of inflection
if the parameters are chosen.
But the underlying potential will be
much more stable representation of what's
going on. Cause the reason
for those little maxima is
the uncertainty principle.
It's the kinetic term in that problem,
which is washing out the details.
So we just faced with a problem.
We want to solve the Schrodinger
equation, Dell squared, Psi Plus v Time,
PSI equals. It can be anything.
So zero is perfectly good.
That's a difference of a constant in the,
and we just want to find the PSI.
We know it's a sum of Gaussians,
Dell squared, cy, we know how to compute.
It's a sum of calciums
multiplied by Paloma polynomials.
The even I can do this problem
and I'm not great at math. Okay,
I take this guy and I move them
over here and I divide by this guy.
And that's v okay, that's, that's
the way we solve the problem.
So now we have an analytic form
for the potential function.
We don't want to have to work with
it, but it's a great form. Okay,
so from that here I have three
Gaussians and 20% variations.
The red curve is the potential function.
The green curve is the way
function. Sigh. Okay. Notice
the gas,
the potential function has very sharp
features even when the Parson estimator
has essentially no features.
So you can run through a huge range
of parameters and nothing changes.
You'll find the same set of minimum.
Here we're looking at two very eight
three very asymmetrical distribution's
different numbers of points
with as the parameters very,
and again this guy is vanishing when this
guy has enormously large features that
we can exercise off. So I've made my
function. I had done what I promised you.
I made my function immensely
insensitive to parameters. Okay.
And I've made it minima instead of Maxima,
which is also cool cause with minimum
I can just do gradient descent and find
them. I can do gradient us sent, but
that's even worse than gradient decent.
This is how funny it can be.
Okay,
this is a 10% or 20% I can't
a 20% variation and I'm
showing you going from no
visible features to
what is apparently flat.
The potential function has the structure
we were looking for and the original
function can't see anything.
You wouldn't be able to make
any money off that function.
So I hope I've convinced you.
Now we've got a good candidate
for a proxy for density.
Now we just have to run guys
downhill as I promised you.
I want to move the points for that. I'll
give you a name. I didn't write it down,
so everybody take out your book.
What I'm going to use as Erin fests,
Erin fests theorem says,
if I have a Gaussian sitting in a
potential and I evolve it using the
Hamiltonian, solve the Schrodinger
equation for the motion of that Gaussian,
the center of the Gaussian will move
according to Newton's laws and the
potential. If I don't go too far, okay?
That's the heart of this trick.
Okay?
The center follows Newton's laws,
but the Gaussian can be,
but the Hamiltonian can be reduced
if I choose a basis to a matrix.
And so exponentiate the Gals,
the Hamiltonian and moving
things is matrix multiplication.
And I can do that on
every single data point.
You give me a million cores and
I'll do it totally in parallel.
And so a million guys,
we'll move delta t in one second.
Okay, now I never have a million
is at my disposal, but if I had it,
that would be a book you could
do. Okay. And so where are we?
Because you're geeks. This is a
pseudo code for the algorithm. Okay.
Step one, read reading data from a
spreadsheet. I want Rosenthal, okay.
To do SVD and make the first frame
of the movie single DQC command.
Make first,
first trajectory,
boom from the data that you did SVD on.
Then you have to choose a basis.
Now what am I mean by choosing a basis?
So this is a long story and I'm not
going to give you all the gory details,
but basically all of these Gaussians
I vectors and Hilbert's space, right?
Everybody who, who's going to follow
me from the rest of this point?
How many people know of vectors in Hilbert
space? Are All of you, none of you.
This is going deep. Okay, I'm already
in trouble. Okay? Uh, they're vectors.
They're independent, they're
not independent. In fact,
there's a look like this.
So the question always is,
how many vectors do I need to create
all the other vectors as linear
combinations of those vectors?
The more important question is,
if I only want to be accurate to 70% how
many vectors do I need in order to get
70% coverage of the data that
I can reconstruct everybody
and get that right at
that level. That's how
you pick a basis. Okay.
I mean it's a story about how
you pick a basis, but that's it.
Then you just have to evaluate
in this basis the kinetic term,
the potential term.
And you,
you try to keep the number of actors
in the basis by adjusting gamma.
So you don't need more
than 1500 2000 vectors.
Cause I don't want to be dealing with
big, major cs. And so by adjusting gamma,
I can get very good coverage for a
fixed number of actors. And by the way,
that's an algorithm for
picking gamma for the problem.
So that takes my freedom of choice out.
Now I can only say who I want,
60% coverage of 50% coverage
and nothing changes very much.
So I don't need to pick gamma.
And then I built a Hamiltonian,
I have to exponentiate that matrix,
eat to a minus,
I times a timestamp times the Hamiltonian.
And then I just go around
multiplying things.
And every time I multiply I find where
the centers of the packets are and I
started again and I keep doing that.
And so after that it's just a loop.
At the end of that loop, I have a movie
and then I just show you the movie.
So what's going on is serious
underneath complicated stuff.
But the movie shows you
everything that's happening.
We don't need to know what's happening,
we only have to know what it's telling me.
And it's telling me where
the higher density locally,
higher density regions are.
And so now the fun is you just go off and
do whatever else you're interested in.
Cause you've seen the
structure of the data.
It's told you where the whales
are hidden in the data. Okay,
you're going to go down and do that.
And so Dq sees benefits are basically
defined by the three nos. No cleaning,
no hypothesis,
no expert knowledge.
I hope I've convinced you it lets you
find hidden unexpected insights and the
big dense data.
Even more so when there's multiple
things going on in the data,
it pulls out the levels of information
just by following your nose.
I mean nobody expected this data to have
stuff going on in tens of thousands of
genes.
But as you keep pulling more and more
genes that you keep seeing that other pot,
the second pattern that means tens of
thousands of genes have been polluted by
the cancer and just it's,
which tells you right away,
it's really easy to convince yourself
that you can diagnose based on information
that has nothing to do with the cost.
Okay?
You have to know the data has this so
that you can go in and see which is more
important because the information
is in tens of thousands of genes.
It's not in a few genes. Okay? So this
is a way of looking at this kind of data.
My colleague hasn't seen I who don't
know much about this kind of, I mean,
the neat thing about this,
why do I love this?
I get to be what I always wanted
to be the consummate Dillard time.
I get to work on a problem not knowing
what it is. I loaded in the data,
I see something my friend comes and says,
that's interesting.
And then we start talking.
And so I only learned about the problem,
what I discovered in the data.
Okay.
And I get to work on in field
after field after field.
And it's why the answer to the question,
why aren't other people using this?
So I'm having such a good time, I'm not
doing a good job of telling the story.
And Burton Richter actually,
who's one of my, uh,
so he's a Nobel prize winning physicist.
He yells at me all the time, he says,
you're having too good a time.
He's on my board and he yells at me,
you are having to go to time.
You're not out there getting
this into the public.
So now I am engaged, uh, in at any rate,
the insights are there and they're
stranger than you might have guessed,
which leads me to quote hamlet that there
were more things and will therefore as
a stranger give it welcomed.
There are more things in heaven and earth,
Horatio then I dreamt of
in your philosophy. Okay.
Datasets have more to say than
you ever guessed they could have.
And there is a tool that can pull the
data apart in a way which lets you see
this is information about the company.
That's my information.
You can get to me and we can
have a conversation. Okay.
I'm done.
Hi.
The first question that was submitted
beforehand is what are the most promising
applications for your technique and how
should Googlers think about potentially
using it? I think you answered a
little bit of the first one, but, um,
I answer to that.
Yeah,
it has to do with I'm a company now
and I've been told by people not to do
certain things. So the truth is we're
not telling anybody this, right?
So, uh, I don't care
what the data comes from.
I did,
I don't use any knowledge of the data
so you can imagine what it's good for.
However,
I have to tell you,
I'm really interested in pursuing one
vertical market because otherwise my
advisers will tell me I'm
doing a terrible thing.
So while I'm pursuing a single vertical,
my first thing frankly is I'd love to,
if there is a market there,
look at a bio,
medicine and Pharma because I think I
showed you that we have the potential to
do precision medicine and then I
can solve my dream of saving lives.
Okay. Which is what I'd
really like to do. Uh,
I have other examples and I welcome
people who want to have a discussion.
I can stay here till
five o'clock. Okay. Uh,
there are examples of the
supply to market segmentation.
Examples applied to dealing with very
noisy data like finding contraband,
nuclear material,
driving around the city of Chicago
with a lousy handheld detector.
Um, there are examples with hyperspectral
camera information. There are,
so you tell me what it's good for.
I leave it in your lap.
A Googlers at the moment.
How can they think about how to apply it?
Talk to me. I mean it, it'll
take some talking. Look,
I'm telling you to do something that
already violates everything that
everybody's ever told you about looking
at data, right? Uh, I'm telling you,
don't clean your data. If you try to
clean your data, I'm gonna slap your hand.
It's not what you learn and
use statistics course. Okay?
The next thing I'm telling you is don't
make a hypothesis because you were an
idiot. You don't know what you're asking.
Okay? You're biasing the result. I mean,
I have people who hate me for saying this,
but that's the best way to
take a first look at data.
The other stuff comes in when you've
understood what's in your data,
when it's shown you what it has to say
to you, what it's told you, which story.
It has a story to tell, but you
have to let it have a voice. Okay.
And this is the way to
let it have a voice.
There may be other ways to let it have
a voice. I just don't know them. Okay.
At anyway. I love this one. It's my baby.
Oh, quite freely admit to bias. Okay.
But uh,
I guess that's the answer to the question.
And anybody who wants to talk to me,
I'm more than happy to talk about it.
In the example of you have
dealt with the cancer cells,
it did you plot the also healthy cells?
I wish I knew that. Right.
We only had six cells.
However you saw I had a hypothesis.
It was the healthy cell data,
but I could nevertheless less prove I
was wrong by only looking at the six cell
information.
Took me a little while to realize all
I had to do was evolve it and see what
would happen.
And if they separated,
it wasn't healthy cell inflammation
because glioblastoma and low grade gliomas
are the same cell.
I couldn't tell from the other cells,
but those two were an indicator.
If they separated,
the information was different for those
two diseases and therefore it wasn't
healthy cell information.
It was pollution of the
genome by the cancer.
I wish I had the information.
I am now looking for people with datasets
that have medical information that,
I mean, all I have is the histologists
said this is thyroid cancer.
Great. So the histologists, it's
a 140 different cancers. Okay.
Even the Glioblastoma,
which is a pretty tight cluster is still
quite a while and extended structure.
It's not one cancer. Okay. The
low grade Gliomas for sure or not.
And there's a connection between
the mid early stages. Okay.
So what is all of that damn define though?
Is there more in this data that
I didn't tell you that? Yes,
but I'm outside of my wheelhouse.
If I talk about it,
it's deeply biological information.
I don't understand it.
My colleague tells me he
doesn't understand that either,
but the biologists so sure.
To be interested in it because nobody's
ever seen that before. Okay. So,
uh, it, it just, it's so much fun
to take a data set of park this way.
I mean your notice I never calculated
a thing. I just made movies.
Yes.
As far as I understand you're
creating this wave function, uh,
uh,
treating those data points as
probability distribution of [inaudible].
They're just functions that are peaked
at the data and then I'm adding them up
and I'm hoping that the resulting function
has maxima where there's more data
and local minima where there's less data.
So I'm plotting the density.
If you start getting into probability
questions and you try to understand this
in some profound way about
probability amplitudes, right?
You're heading down a rabbit hole that
you shouldn't be going down. Okay.
It's a trick.
This is normous problem to me because
people love quantum mechanics. It's,
it's, I love quantum mechanics.
It's fabulous. But I'm
abusing corner mechanics.
I am taking what I know from
quantum mechanics and all
the years I spent knowing
how to solve problems, not
perturber differently. Okay.
And I'm stealing them to do a problem,
which is like,
it's not 100% light gradient descent.
You really want to be
mystified a little bit.
Why can I work in a hundred or a thousand
dimensions when other people fail in
10? Well, I happen to know why they fail.
The reason they fail is if you would
have formed this probability this, uh,
so you've got me doing it,
shame on you. At any rate,
uh, if you were to take this, uh,
potential function and look
at it under a microscope,
you would see that little ripples
form because as the dimension goes up,
statistical small statistical
fluctuations start to happen a lot.
Okay?
That's what everybody gets stuck in.
If they try doing kneeling
or something like that,
they find too many clusters.
I want to see only the big shape
then envelops that whole thing.
So I didn't tell you about the
other parameter in the problem.
The other parameter which was set to one
when I made the potential function is
the mass of the particle.
There's moving quantum mechanics.
That's a wonderful thing called tunneling.
If I make that mass
lower than one like 0.1,
it's not going to see the little minimum.
They vanish it tunnels through them.
So in fact you only CVN developing
big potential and so I can work.
I have worked in 1,024 dementia.
Well it's two things are happening
as the mask will go offline. Okay.
Not Fair to other people
for us to get a yes,
but sometimes it just goes through.
Um,
another question from the Dory.
Early quantum computers won't have many
cubits are long coherence times how you
get big data sets into the machine
before the cubits. Decohere
I'm not doing quantum computing,
I'm doing classical computing.
I don't need to answer that question.
Next question.
Uh, what have you found DQC is more
effective than other ML techniques?
Have you found heuristics as to why
that is? I think you also answered
a little bit. I tried to answer
that all through this thing. I mean,
I can say it again.
So not only don't I care about the data,
I don't care about the
size of the Dataset. Okay.
If you run this on small data
sets, which it was done. Okay.
There's something that people use for
the small datasets called as your card
score. I think some of you are
familiar with that. I don't like it,
but it's the main figure of mirror.
So applied to small datasets,
Nicu seizure card scores run from 0.8
seventh the 0.96 when I spoke to somebody
at Hanford labs, he was a spook and he
said, what kind of is your card scores?
These you said? I said,
I don't do that. Great.
I do 0.8 6.9 he said I kill for 0.86.
Okay. Uh, so we do very well,
but why am I interested in
small data sets and know why?
Small datasets,
anybody can get an answer on when
a Dataset has no separations in it.
When you plot it earned him many
methods that can touch that problem.
Okay.
The HDD scans as it can touch it
and only works up to 10 dimensions.
Number one and it degrades badly
and 10 dimensions, but number two,
you also saw kids the wrong answer for
reasons having to do with the data set.
It's complex and more than
one thing that's going on,
it doesn't know what he's looking for.
DQC somehow avoids that.
It's hidden in the density of the
data in the high dimensions. Okay.
I mean it just past that
point, I already proved to you,
I can visualize the data in 48 dimensions
that tell you how the answer is going
to come out. Thought I
did, but I was wrong.
Nice thing is I can't make the QC do what
I want. It'll do what it's going to do.
I have a question.
So if I have a large,
a high dimensional data set,
is the other use cases where you would
not recommend to QC or I was killing
these guys over lunch? I love
that question. So I'm a physicist.
I believe everything has a
failure mode. Okay. Absolutely.
Believe that with my gut,
I spent five years trying to find
the Dataset it doesn't work on. Okay.
I thought I had it. Okay. I thought
I had an Alzheimer's Dataset,
which somebody gave me and it was 1500
Alzheimer's pay or 3000 I don't remember.
And it was 250,000 snips.
And they said,
so the information we want to know,
can you see people who would have laid
out onset Alzheimer's and people who
won't based on these snips?
And so I ran the data,
so I dunno where they ran it in,
but when I looked,
it was something like a hundred
150 dimensions was appropriate.
I could get reconstruct the whole
Dataset to the 1% level by that.
So there's no point in running
and 250,000 dimensions. Okay,
I'll run in a hundred and something.
I saw lots of stuff.
Unfortunately what I saw is what 23
[inaudible] or ancestry.com I saw what was
probably, I didn't have the
information was most certainly, uh,
data that had to do with ethnicity.
Okay.
But when I looked at all
of the clusters that I had,
and I calculated the
number of people who had,
had been autopsied and shown to have
Alzheimer's and the number that were
autopsied insurance, so they
own, unfortunately, they
were all dead and I hope,
and uh,
they were shown to have Alzheimer's
and not have Alzheimer's.
The distribution in the general population
and the distribution in the clusters
up to 1% variations, it's
the same. So finally,
after knocking myself out,
trying to vary the parameters I have,
and of course I couldn't get a different
answer. I called the guys up and said,
I'm sorry you say this stuff there,
I don't see a thing.
There's just nothing else.
I'm is related in your data.
I think eva talked to the proteomics
group at Stanford Hospital and they asked
me this wonderful question, what's
your failure mode? And I said,
I failed a Bismal Leon [inaudible] data.
And,
and I was proud I had a
failure mode. And he said, uh,
I know the Dataset you just talked about.
We worked on it for 10 years.
There's nothing in that data center.
So,
you know,
my week spent looking at the Dataset
four times was not in the end wasted,
but I still don't know my thallium
I'm sorry. I wish I knew it. No,
I it has to be there. You can't work on
everything. Nothing works on everything.
I just haven't gotten unlucky or lucky.
I don't know which it would be,
but it would be nice to know
what the limitations are.
Density variations is such a robust thing.
It's such a different way
of looking at the data that
it's hard to see when it fails.
Thank you so much.
Um, we were talking maybe for one
more question. There's any live,
we can also get one from the dory.
MMM.
Oh, this was sort of just ask,
but what are the downsides?
DQC Why isn't everyone using it right now?
I guess this is part of,
it's my fault.
My wife was sitting here, so I don't
want to say it again. She'll yell at me.
It's my fault. In some sense
it's my fault. Okay. Uh,
I don't think I've been the best spokesman
for recruiting young people to jump
on the bandwagon and start doing it
cause I've been having too good at time
using it and,
and I guess that's been my problem
through life. Okay. I mean,
I always got yelled at by the head of
the lab that you got to write another
paper you're not sharing.
He says you are having too good a time
knowing what we don't know and you're not
sharing. And uh, probably I
don't share enough. Right.
So you invited me and I'm sharing.
Thank you.
Wow.
Well
thank you for sitting through it.